Hey,
what's up guys?
All right,
I like to start these things kind of slow as we let,
uh,
the video populate and get into people's feeds and let you guys jump in over
here.
Obviously for all of these live streams that I've done for Patrion,
we usually we're doing them or for the years that we've been doing them,
we were doing them,
uh,
behind the Patriot wall.
So the link was only going out to patrons and patrons were asking me questions
and we weren't making these public to everybody last month we decided to make
them public to everybody but only patrons,
uh,
could ask me questions.
Um,
so this obviously is going out to my,
my full feed.
So a,
actually we're about to cross 900,000 subscribers I think today,
probably a,
so I'm psyched about that.
I,
there's a ton of stuff I'm super psyched about at the moment.
That being said,
we've got a lot to talk about related to the,
the Sargon of a cod patrion situation and uh,
sort of the subsequent fallout from that and where that leaves a whole bunch of
us business wise,
where it leaves what I'm doing with you guys and everything else.
Um,
so I'm going to take plenty of questions here and I'm going to be as open and
honest with you about what I'm going through right now and what I think this
Sargon vanning needs in the wider world of platforming and D platforming and the
rest of it.
And sort of what I'm thinking my future should be related to all of this and how
we can keep doing these things and keep them,
hopefully fan funded,
but that there's a lot of other options and that generally just what the hell is
going on right now.
So,
okay,
so let me just start slowly with what happened.
If you don't know what happened here,
let me tell you what's going on.
If you've been under an Internet rock for a couple of days,
uh,
about five or six days ago,
Sargon of a cod who's a big youtuber,
has about 800,000 subscribers.
He's been doing it for a long time,
uh,
was banned on Patriot.
Now quickly,
for those of you that don't know Sargon at all,
Sargon uh,
when I started years ago,
let's say five years ago when I started really realizing that something was
rotten on the left and I saw how that was so connected to free speech and then I
saw the rise of these social justice warriors who were hysterical and wanting to
silence everybody.
And then when I started,
all of this was leaking into what I saw was happening with the progressive
movement.
When I started talking about that on youtube,
everybody was saying,
you've got to go talk to Sargon of Akkad.
You've got to talk to it.
Him,
he is the guy that has been sounding the alarms on this thing.
You got to talk to them.
Anyway,
I did end up talking to him on his channel.
Uh,
and I tell you that because he was sort of the first one of the liberals that
was like,
guys,
what's going on with us?
We're not acting liberal anymore.
And then of course,
that leads to everything that I've talked about over these couple of years,
right?
Like the left is no longer liberal.
The progressive's have purged,
they're free thinkers.
And it's becoming an authoritarian movement that is against liberalism,
which is rooted in the individual and,
and live and let live acting.
Okay.
So because our God is not a nobody,
he's not just some random youtuber.
He's actually been in the studio.
I've interviewed him.
His name is Carl Benjamin.
You might be interested in finding it out.
Eric Weinstein had an interesting comment on Carl,
uh,
that he's told me the other day.
He said,
you sort of a blue collar intellect,
which I think is actually a great compliment.
It's like he doesn't,
he's not a pure intellectual like,
you know,
that is,
that is studied at all of these universities for years and years.
Am I not to become a professor?
And the rest of it and the published off there,
et cetera.
Uh,
but he knows these ideas in and out.
but he's blue collar and that he's a regular guy.
He's,
he's a bit of a admitted troll.
He likes fighting with people online.
He loves me makers.
He was sort of born out of Gamergate,
all of those things.
Okay.
The point is the guy is not a racist and here is what happened or as far as I
know,
the guy is not a racist,
but let me tell you why he got bad.
He was banned because patrion found a video a few days ago from 10 months ago,
from February of this year on another channel,
not even his channel,
uh,
where he was being interviewed over audio with someone and the guy's not a
native English speaker,
so there's a little bit of a stilted conversation and Sargon says the n word,
I think he says it at least twice now.
He was saying it because he was trying to use the language of the alt right
against them.
He was mocking their use and their,
the way they think about certain people based on the color of their skin.
Okay.
So I even said,
so now let me back up for a second.
So when I found out that Sargon got banned,
I immediately texted Jack Conti,
who is the CEO of Patriot and I've had jack in this studio.
Okay.
Right across from me where this computer is.
Basically,
he sat there and that was when Lauren southern was banned and,
and Jack Con d said that we do not ban people over speech.
We ban people over manifest observable behavior mob mob.
You can't make that up.
People mob.
Okay.
That's what they ban people over mob behavior.
Irony is,
that's not even,
I already,
it's so ridiculous.
It's not even already.
Anyway,
he used my platform to say what his company's policy were and they were not
about banning people over speech.
Also,
he had made a point of saying,
and it is in their terms of service,
that it has to be an infraction that occurs on their platform.
So in this case,
not only did Sargon not say the word on their platform,
it wasn't even on his youtube channel that he's promoting them for patron
Patrion,
right?
It was on someone else's channel,
a small channel with like 4,000 subscribers in this case.
So this went against all the terms of service.
They,
they booted him without any warning and no chance of appeal or anything like
that.
And people are seriously pissed right now and I get why they're pissed.
I'm pissed.
And on all the last three days,
I mean,
this basically,
I've met a lot going on these last couple of days as I finally ended the tour
with Peterson,
although we're,
we're continuing again in the new year.
Uh,
but we taped like five shows in the last two days were,
were finishing seriously strong for the,
for the end of the year.
We got some great stuff coming.
Um,
but this has taken every other moment of my life because this is a direct,
not only is it related completely to free speech and everything that I talk
about constantly and what's going on with these platforms in these companies.
Um,
but it's also directly related to my business.
So just Fyi at the moment we've lost about 500 patrons and that's been,
I think it's around five or 6,000 bucks a month that we've lost.
Now most of the people have messaged me and said,
I'm really sorry Dave.
I love what you're doing.
This has nothing to do with you.
This is a stand against patriot.
Now the funny thing here is that I'm actually at one level,
I'm very inspired that these people are you guys,
right?
You guys are just like,
you know what?
Fuck this.
I can't take this shit anymore.
We have,
we have known this is coming,
these,
these lines of what is acceptable and what's not acceptable.
Keep moving and moving and moving and Sargon.
I don't know everything about the guy,
but if this guy is the type of person that cannot be on a platform,
then half the people I know probably can't be on a platform and that may include
me and that probably includes you.
So we keep letting these things move.
Again,
it doesn't matter what you think about Alex Jones,
but you take out one.
It's not like when they take out one person,
they're like,
ah,
we got one person,
we're good to go.
Let's pack it in guys.
Let's find a new hobby.
It's like,
oh,
well who can we keep moving?
Who can we keep moving?
Can we keep moving?
And the thing is,
when I started,
uh,
my Patrion hangouts today,
so this is,
this is the day that we do the rewards where I do these small Google hangouts
with people.
Um,
right before I started,
you can look at my last tweet or two tweets ago,
vox,
that awful steaming pile of poop that is vox,
which is funded to hundreds of millions of dollars a year yet is obsessed with a
couple of Youtube burrs.
Um,
wrote a piece where they're calling a whole bunch of us once again of usual
suspects.
They're calling a whole bunch of us all right and reactionary,
right?
And the rest of it.
And it's like,
man,
will you keep doing that?
And then eventually,
why wouldn't these platforms,
Buddhas?
So I have a vested interest in having this thing stopped because eventually it's
going to come from me.
And by the way,
if you're like the things I'm talking about,
it's probably going to come for you too.
So I'm,
I'm oddly inspired on some level that people are kind of standing up and they're
saying we're not going to put our money,
uh,
to companies that aren't,
don't support what we believe in or at least respect free speech and whatever
else.
And then at the same time,
I'm taking a business hits,
so I'm not sure what to do.
So let me just throw out just one quick little promo thing here.
Um,
if you can go to Dave Rubin,
not if you can,
if you'd like to go to Dave rubin.com/donate,
you can donate there.
Uh,
and keep the show independent.
We are a hundred percent independent.
I am my boss.
I am the CEO of this company.
We are a,
we have several employees now.
The morning that this all went down.
We just actually flipped one of our part timers to a full or,
um,
I'm the,
I'm super proud of what we've built here.
We built a great community beyond just the conversations we're having,
all of that.
I've traveled the world this year and met thousands and thousands of you guys.
It's,
it's all good.
It's all good.
Um,
and if you want to help us keep it independent and you're not happy with what's
going on,
on Patrion on,
you can go to Dave rubin.com/donate.
You can do a one time donation or a monthly donation.
Paypal credit card.
Doesn't matter.
Okay,
so that,
I just wanted to say that because a lot of you guys are asking me,
um,
I spent the last couple of days really,
really,
really trying to figure out what to do about this.
I wrote a statement that I almost published where I was going to announce that I
was leaving patrion on.
I was going to do something nuts.
I mean a normal person,
a normal person in business doesn't voluntarily kiss 65 or 70% of their monthly
revenue.
Goodbye,
but I was going to do it because I really thought like,
we're not going to get many more of these moments.
You know what I mean?
It's a little bit like you don't want to swing too early when something's
happened and you don't want to swing too late.
You want to swing right at the right moment,
but we don't know when that right moment is anymore.
These,
these bands and these shadow bands and algorithmic nonsense,
it all seems so arbitrary and ridiculous that we don't know when it is going to
happen.
You know what I mean?
Like it's very possible that ever that right now there's a Google engineer
watching this right now going,
Oh man,
I hope you will just slip up and say something.
Say the word that Sargon said so I can give him the boot to,
I mean we just don't know what the hell is going on here.
But I do know that the CEO Patrion sat in my studio and said this is about
behavior and these are about things that happen on the platform.
And,
and either he changed or he lied to me or he doesn't know what he's talking
about.
And I'm not even making this up to throw Jack Conte under the bus being like
seal or one of these companies probably sucks.
And every day you're just under assault from social justice warriors who want to
destroy another human being.
And by the way,
this is permeating society at every level right now.
The Oscars can't even find a freaking host because they had Kevin Hart and then
apparently he said faggot and now he can't host the Oscars.
I mean everything is,
is just nonsense and drivel and we must stand up against it.
And I think you guys are getting a little bolder in standing up against it.
I meet people who are starting to get more engaged.
I think people are realizing it's coming to all of our doorsteps.
If we don't do it,
and again,
as I say every freaking week,
I'm just some guy,
I don't know why I'm doing this.
I'm not a superhero,
but we've got to get better at this.
We've got to get better at organizing and fighting this.
Anyway,
what I've realized is it would not be wise or make any business sense to just
kiss 70% of my revenue goodbye and hope that a whole bunch of people are going
to go and donate on my site.
I do.
There's a lot of things I want to do on that and to fix things.
But what I would say is at the moment,
if we can migrate as much as many people from patrion and new people over today,
ruby.com/donate it will give me the leverage I need to do what I think is right.
That being said,
what you can do it or not do it.
It's all good.
Either way,
we'll figure it out and I'm not sitting here like cry me a river.
I want to solve this problem.
And I,
and I can't get into all the conversations I've had about this,
but I,
but many of the people that,
um,
that you know and admire who are,
who are friends of mine that have been on the show and all that,
um,
they're thinking about what to do too.
Like everybody is,
I,
I think I can say that much.
Everybody is realizing this is a escalation of this,
that if we let this guy go down and we don't make anything of it,
it's not about him specifically,
but if we let another person go down who doesn't deserve to go down,
it's coming.
It's coming.
And it's getting bolder every time because nobody stands up to it.
So we got to stock start standing up more.
So I'm happy to take any of your questions on that.
I'm happy to take a whole bunch of questions on,
on a series of things.
Um,
and we'll,
we'll figure it out.
I mean,
look,
there's lots of options.
I've had ad agencies reach out to me in the last couple of days and they're
asking me if I want to start reading ads on the youtube show.
You know,
I don't really want to do that.
I don't really want to do that,
but maybe that is a safer financial route than going fully fan funded.
But I love being fan funded.
Like I'm free.
I'm truly free.
You know,
we were,
we get,
I mean,
I'll just tell you guys like we'd get,
Patriot is our number one read source.
We get youtube red,
which is obviously all over the place.
And then we do have ads on our audio podcasts.
The only other thing that we've ever had in terms of revenue,
you know,
a little bit on merge,
whatever.
Um,
the only other thing we ever had was we had that partnership with learn liberty
for two years,
which we ended in June.
They wanted to continue it actually.
And I just felt like we could try some new things.
So I am talking to some other nonprofits about maybe doing some other things on
the side.
Um,
but you know that that's what our revenue streams are.
So maybe there are some other ways we can,
we can do some other things.
One of the silly thing on revenue,
uh,
just cause I think this will help frame a little bit of this for you guys.
So,
you know,
we had Shapiro and Peterson in here on,
uh,
last Friday and um,
the video as a last I saw has around 1.1 million views.
It's a two hour video.
It's,
I think it's one of the best things we've ever done in the studio.
I think we got the best that have been the best out of Jordan.
I think we covered new ground.
We went deep on religion,
um,
talked about differences and similarities and I thought it was really excellent.
It operated.
It's sort of a very high bar.
There were moments where I had to sort of dumb it down because I want,
I want,
I want regular people to be able to understand these things too.
Um,
anyway,
two hour video,
uh,
over 1 million views.
Um,
the average watch time on it.
Last I saw it was about 40 minutes,
which is obscene.
Leila.
Hi for Youtube,
right?
Like think about the last time you watch a 40 minute video on youtube,
What do you do?
You watch a kid fall down,
you watch somebody get hit in the nuts,
you watch a cat and then you watch a 10 minute chat and then whatever else you
watch,
any little little basketball,
whatever,
somebody playing video games.
Okay,
so that's an incredible amount of content that people are watching.
For a long time,
that video last I saw,
I had generated I around 5,000 bucks.
Um,
so now think about that.
If that had been on CNN or just anything on prime time,
two hours of where a million people were watching.
Now to give that a little context and NBC nightly news,
they tell you,
I think average is around 1.4 million views and night.
So basically that video got roughly,
or by the end of this week,
let's say we'll have the same amount that NBC news gets on any given night.
Think about the revenue that NBC news generates from all the advertisers that
are,
they probably are making millions of dollars that night.
That video made us 5,000 bucks.
So the economics of this whole thing are all at a whack too.
And I think that that's also causing some of potential.
Uh,
anyway,
that's why we,
we obviously are on Patrion on,
and again,
I'm not saying any of this to cry me a river.
I'm just saying it because I'm trying to be as transparent as I possibly can be
with you guys as we're at a strange crossroads,
which is also sort of
funny or odd for me because this has been such an incredible year.
I mean,
I did about a hundred stops with Peterson.
I started doing standup again.
We're selling out all these clubs.
Um,
I just got back from a Gig at University of Wyoming,
300 great young people,
conservatives who are happy to,
um,
talk about ideas.
And when we did the Q and a,
we had people come up first who disagreed with me.
Um,
so I'm feeling so great about everything and the show has grown.
We're going to cross 900,000 subscribers today or tomorrow.
Um,
there,
there's so many good things happening that it's just great.
So it's kind of funny now that we're,
we're ending the year on this odd note relative to the business,
which is so relative to the core issues that we're talking about,
about platforming and free speech and everything else.
So anyway,
that's all that I have a feeling I'm going to have about a gazillion questions
about all of this stuff.
So let's see.
Um,
when is must going to kick off his version of Youtube?
It could it be called dark tube.
I Dunno.
You know,
I've never been connected with Alon.
Obviously we're a,
we have a couple of connections in,
in,
uh,
in our worlds.
Um,
but we need somebody to get on,
get in on this.
You know,
I think there's been some chatter from the billionaire class,
but it's like,
we need you guys,
if you happen to be a billionaire and you're watching this right now,
uh,
hello.
Uh,
you can email me right at Dave Ruben dotcom contact.
You'll find it.
Um,
okay.
I will follow you to paypal or anywhere else other than Patrion just announced
where to go and I'll follow you.
You do good work.
Well,
thank you very much.
It's just Dave rubin.com/donate and you can do monthly.
You can do one time,
whatever it is.
Um,
what are the IDW members willing to do about solving the issue versus hoping
someone else will do it instead,
fans leaving?
Patrion uh,
me too before the end of the year are taking action.
Where's the action from our thought leaders?
What a great question,
right?
This is what it's all about.
Like one of the things that I've said repeatedly over the last year is that I
don't want these conversations just to remain conversations.
I want to figure out how to put these ideas into action.
How do we get,
um,
politicians elected that,
that may be believe in some of these things?
How do we get the Democrats to return to liberalism,
let's say,
um,
which by in turn would then maybe a moderate,
moderate,
make the Republican's a little more moderate,
something like that.
Um,
we're all talking about it.
I can't,
I mean I just can't,
I can't tell you the nature of all of the private conversations.
But what I can tell you is that everyone that you think might be thinking about
this is thinking about it and trying to figure out what to do.
And it's like we all have different considerations,
right?
We all have different businesses.
Some of us are professors and authors,
some of us are on speaking tours.
Some of us are generating more rev through youtube.
I mean,
we're all trying to figure out,
some of them aren't even on Patrion at all,
but,
but understand the gravity of the situation.
So everyone's trying to figure it out.
Just try to be patient with us.
Which sucks too because it's like,
man,
the more patient we are,
we're just giving room,
right?
We're just giving room for these guys to come in and swoop down and knock out
the next one.
And it's like the more hysterical these,
these,
what's acceptable to be said is so like,
you know,
if you miss gender or dead name,
I'd never heard this phrase deadnamed Cornell.
If you dead name someone.
Meaning,
if,
if a trans person goes by,
um,
Alison,
but their old name was Andy,
if you call them handy,
you could be banned on Twitter.
I mean,
these really,
really,
really Orwellian speech codes.
They could come to get anybody.
I either because someone's making a joke or you know,
in a case of,
uh,
let's say Shapiro,
it's like facts don't care about your feelings.
I'm going to say what I think I've related to how many genders there are or
whatever else it is.
So it's a mess.
And I,
and trust me,
we're,
we're trying,
we're trying to figure it out.
Okay.
Um,
let's see.
Plans for John mcwhorter to come on the show also where you were.
Chapstick.
I ship you some.
My Lips are always dry.
That those,
can I get some chap stick in here?
I'm going to put on some chap stick right now.
Little Chap stick would be nice.
Um,
they're a little dry.
A little dry.
All right,
good.
So we'll get a little chapstick in here.
Um,
hey,
Dave just subscribes your website.
Thanks for the critical work that you do.
Thank you very much.
A chapstick.
Apparently this livestream is brought to you buy Burt's bees.
So there you go.
Alright.
And I've got no got moist lips.
Okay,
there we go.
Let's see.
Here we go.
Um,
I feel like there's group think in television.
I hear the pundits United in one agenda and saying practically the same thing.
So are the heads of studios in charge and the people on television,
um,
and thus the people on television willing to say what they are told in exchange
for money,
status,
fame.
Um,
oh,
I see.
Are The people,
look,
I try not to judge people's motives,
so I don't know when you,
you know,
it's funny,
I was in the gym the other day.
I'd never watched CNN anymore.
It's just painful.
It's just dribble endless Trump,
Russia dribble you will not get smarter.
You will get dumber watching this.
Um,
but every now and again in the gym it's on,
and I'll flip the,
and I'm like,
all right,
let me just pause and watch this.
I don't know,
like,
do these people intentionally ask the stupid questions?
Did they intentionally conflate and confuse the issues?
I don't know.
Are some people more opportunistic than others and just one fame and fortune or
I guess that's probably true.
Or some people probably not that bright and maybe that helps them succeed in a
talking head world.
That's probably true too.
Um,
so yeah,
it's why people are tuning out of these things.
No one's paying attention to these things and in a way that's why they're,
they're cracking down on so many of us.
I mean,
think about it.
Why is vox again today and it's not the first time they've done it writing an
article that basically is trying to link me in Shapiro and Lacy Green and a and
a couple others.
Um,
to the alt right.
It's like,
you know why they're doing it because they're threatened by this.
So vox,
which is tuned to,
you know,
like $200 million worth of VC money is worried about what a bunch of of upstart
youtubers are doing because you can see we're getting all the clicks,
we're getting all the views,
we're getting all the retweets and it's like,
go look at,
go right now.
Go look at,
um,
I just pick,
let me pick something that's hot,
like do,
do,
do this test for me and someone can comment on it and I'll,
and I'll read it,
look at buzzfeed or Huffington Post's last 10 tweets and then look at my last 10
tweets and tell me which one has more traction.
And there is no doubt that mind doing a couple of minor just promotions of this,
which isn't the type of thing that gets a lot of traction,
but I guarantee you if you were add all those up.
Mine we way,
way,
way bigger.
Um,
so they,
they've had it with other interesting people who don't think like they do
getting clicks and views and making people have conversation and,
and having people be enlightened instead of,
um,
okay.
Drill down to the point of stupidity.
So yeah,
it's a mess.
Um,
admittedly you have learned and grown from speaking to a variety of people.
You said that your interview with Larry Elder Change Your viewpoint about
systemic racism.
Has another guest fundamentally changed another point of view.
Um,
that's a really good question.
You know,
you know,
when I came back last year,
last September,
when I did that off the grid thing,
uh,
not this past summer,
but the summer before,
that was the first time where I did the August completely off the grid.
And when I came back,
um,
I had said that although I had always sort,
or at least for the last couple of years,
I thought of myself as an atheist that I didn't really like the term.
I didn't like the word.
For me,
it doesn't really capture a what I am because it's not,
I don't have a sort of lack of belief,
but I,
I do believe in something that I can't quite explain exactly what it is.
So I just didn't want to use the term atheist who explain it anymore.
I can tell you that in the last year I'm having these conversations,
uh,
with Shapiro and Peterson and I just had a great conversation yesterday.
It will be up next week.
Excuse me with Bishop Barron,
who's been on the show,
who's from the archdiocese here in la,
and with Rabbi Wolpe,
who is the rabbi at Temple Sinai in Beverly Hills.
We had a great conversation,
which I thought would be perfect to do right between Hanukkah and Christmas.
Oh,
by the way,
I also had,
yesterday,
I had a mom too.
Weedy on,
that'll be up next week.
So my last three interviews with a rabbi,
a rabbi,
a priest,
and any mom walk into a gay podcast.
There's garage,
there's an old joke.
Um,
but I would say I've been moved on
the,
look,
this is a whole,
like,
we,
I could end up doing three hours on this thing.
Um,
but I've been moved on on a certain value of religion.
It doesn't mean everyone has to be religious.
I'm not religious,
but a certain value in belief of sort of an unmoved mover kind of thing.
Um,
you know,
I've seen Jordan in these hundred or so shows that we've done together really
stretches knowledge on this and really explain the value of these stories and
that there are certain ancient truths that can't be,
um,
that not every truth that exists can be empirically proven or that science and
logic alone aren't enough to explain all of the driving forces that make us
human and make us love and hate and all of those other things.
Um,
so I would say that's one that I'm,
I'm sort of evolving on,
which is actually kind of cool.
Um,
and it's,
and it's also like a very much an affirmation of,
you know,
that I'm doing something good for a living because I don't mean this to be sappy
or sarcastic even.
But like I sit across from people every day that I can learn something from and
if I can just keep my mind open enough to learn something,
um,
or even here something that I disagree with and then that makes my belief
reinforce,
uh,
afterwards,
that's pretty cool too.
So,
um,
I would say I'm,
I would,
I'm evolving on some of that stuff.
I think it's a great conversation.
I think the fact that so many people are thinking about it,
that we can do videos on the nature of reality and,
and the nature of truth.
And can you get value out of faculty on the p the fact that people care about
this and not just a couple people,
but millions and millions of people care about it.
I mean,
that's,
that's pretty awesome.
Um,
do you ever get confused with David Ruben,
the author also?
Do you have a book in you?
So first off,
that's hilarious.
I was on Tucker Carlson last night and are before me was David Ruben,
who is a mayor,
a former mayor in Israel.
So a lot of people were confused because I was like,
I'll be on Tucker Carlson tonight.
And then they tune in and there's a guy,
David Rubin,
older guy,
white hair,
uh,
in Israel.
That was not me.
Um,
also,
do you have a book in you?
So,
yeah.
Um,
Eh,
you know what,
I'm just going to do it.
Uh,
we signed my book deal finally.
it's with a big publisher.
I'm super psyched.
I can't,
I don't know that I can fully say everything.
Um,
but I'm writing it right now.
it is going to be the most difficult thing that I've ever done.
That is very obvious.
Uh,
I'm trying to get seriously,
deeply personal and not just political.
Um,
but the deal is done,
the advances has hit the checking account.
Um,
and uh,
and I'm psyched to do something that I think we'll be,
we'll be real and relevant and it'll be out,
uh,
months before the 2020 election.
I want to get,
you know,
cause then it's like they're just going to put our political book after
political book and it's just going to be awful.
Um,
so I think it's going to be out in September.
I'm sorry,
in the spring.
Probably March or April of 2020.
I know that seems like a long time from now.
I have to have the manuscript in by August 1st and it just takes time.
It seems weird in this world of like such quick stuff happening all the time and
live streams and all this other stuff.
But yeah,
it'll,
it'll be,
uh,
out then and I'm psyched and it's going to be a lot of work.
But you know,
what else am I doing?
Um,
are you ever worried that your platform on youtube can be completely taken away?
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah.
Like how can I watch the tea leaves change?
How can I watch Sargon be booted from Patrion and other people be booted from
Twitter and people be kicked off Youtube and some people get reinstated.
And how can I watch all of these things happen and not think,
oh man,
it could come for me.
Maybe not even cause it's saying,
I said,
what if I had a guest on who went on a crazy racist tirade?
Well,
we know what box would write about it.
We know what buzzfeed would write about it.
And then eventually we know what the trolls would do and they'd be flagging,
flagging,
and then eventually a youtube may be like,
you know what?
Enough of this headache.
So that's why there is a technological answer to this.
Maybe there's a block chain based video site coming up.
Maybe people need to use more crypto to support the creators that they like.
Um,
but I think whatever you guys can do in your life to fight back,
whether that's talking about these ideas or protesting,
if you do it within the confines of the law or going to or not using services if
you don't like them,
which is why as I said earlier,
I'm watching my patrion money drop and I'm kind of inspired by it because it's
like at least you guys are doing something.
Um,
and by the way,
some people are going to my site,
they're not just abandoning me all together,
but you're going to lose,
you know,
you know how it is online.
It's like you're doing one thing and next thing you knew in 10 other things or
looking at another video and like you just forget.
So you're like,
oh,
I cancel this.
I let me go over to Dave rubin.com.
But then by the time you get there,
you're already playing video games or something.
And you just forget it.
It's just,
it's just how it is.
So it's Dave ruben.com/donate um,
but I'm of course I'm worried about all of those things.
I think we don't have an organized voice.
We don't have a sensible plan fully yet.
I mean,
I think there's a lot of discussion about what,
what should happen and how do we fight this thing.
But I don't think we've solved it yet and we got a lot of work to do.
Um,
do you get criticized by the LGBT community for associating with or interviewing
those of faith that disagree with homosexuality?
So,
yeah.
Um,
I don't know what the LGBT community is.
It's funny when people talk about the black community or the LGBT community.
I mean,
that's the type of collectivism that I don't like because within those
communities,
of course,
you're going to have a truly diverse group of people,
meaning all sorts of people think differently.
You're not going to believe this,
but black people often have different thoughts that have nothing to do with the
color of their skin.
And Gay people often have different thoughts that have nothing to do with their
sexuality.
I'm not,
I'm not commenting on you specifically person who asked me this question,
but uh,
but I do it too.
Sometimes I'll say the community,
then I'm like,
what?
What does that really mean?
You know,
you can get general trends,
let's say out of the community.
Um,
yeah,
I get shit from,
you know,
did you see this article and dead spin the other day?
There was a title.
The title of the article was gay conservatives should shut the fuck up.
Think about that for a second.
The title of the piece that was tweeted out,
gay conservatives should shut the fuck up.
These are a supposedly the tolerant people,
and B,
these are supposedly the pro gay people,
right?
These are the lefties were,
we're tolerant and we love gays.
You know,
we love minorities,
but they don't,
and you really need to understand that they love you.
If you bow,
that's it.
They don't love you because you're gay.
They love you as long as you'll behave.
They're not for women to say you're four women.
Everyone's for women.
It's meaningless to say you're for women.
I'm,
I want everyone on this earth to be treated equally under the law and live with
a sense of dignity and hopefully find something that they're passionate about
and live the best life they can live.
I'm for women in that.
I want women to be part of that.
But to say you're four women are the women who run the women's March,
are they for Nikki Haley,
who I think is a spectacular woman,
she's the former governor of South Carolina who was the US representative at the
UN for the last two years.
And maybe one day she'll be president of the United States.
She happens to be a brown woman and that she's Indian,
but she's a Republican.
Are you for Nikki Haley?
You're not for Nikki Haley.
You're not for Sarah Huckabee Sanders.
You're not for women who disagree.
So to say your four groups is actually ridiculous related to the gay thing.
Um,
well it's interesting because it's like I never get,
not that anyone cares about the gay press or the advocate or out or any of those
things anywhere.
Nobody reads them anymore.
But it's like you'd think that maybe they'd write an article about me because I
am openly gay and I'm doing this and people seem to care about it.
Right.
Daily wire just did really cool interview with me that I was,
I was really,
uh,
happy to do.
Um,
so it's not for lack that I wouldn't want to talk to these people,
but I'm out or advocate.
I forget which one,
about two or three years ago wrote a piece that Peter Teal,
who's also openly gay,
who spoke at the Republican national convention before Trump accepted the
nomination.
He went up there,
he said,
I'm a proud gay man and got a standing ovation at the Republican National
Convention that was very under reported by the way.
You can't imagine why.
Um,
but outer advocate wrote an article saying,
Peter teals not gay because they've decided that your sexuality is in your
sexuality.
It's how you behave out.
If you were in the line with their political views,
then you can be gay.
But he's not gay because he,
he votes for people that we don't like.
I mean,
think how that's actually offensive.
Like,
it's hard to offend me,
but that's actually events.
It.
Um,
what I can tell you is this,
which is much more inspiring than what I've just said is that,
um,
on the last year or so where I've done a hundred stops and we were in probably
15 different countries.
And why don't,
you know,
people coming up to me in Helsinki and Stockholm on the street and Amsterdam at
a store and where and everywhere in Kansas City and in Orlando and in San Diego,
um,
that gay people come up to me all the time and they'll be like,
what happened to the gate?
We used to be fun.
We used to be edgy.
We used to care about music and dance and being the other and it win for the
pain,
for a pain.
Right.
It was pain that brought that because a community that wasn't treated equally
because these people could not get married often.
That,
that internal,
whatever,
that internal pain caused,
great art caused great humor,
all of those things in music and all of that,
well now we're equal and maybe some of that pain is gone,
which I think is actually good because now we can be treated as shittily as
everybody else.
But when you're not equal under the law,
then you do deserve to be equal under the law.
Um,
and you might act out differently.
So I think people are now seeing that as the progressive's have sort of
infiltrated the gay community,
that gays aren't that fun anymore.
So I think a lot of gays are breaking.
I think it's a little bit also of what Candice Owens has done with the black
community,
so to speak.
Uh,
so there's interesting things happening right now.
Um,
I'd like to pose the same question that you pose to Bridgette Gabriel.
What has been the personal costs for what you do?
Um,
well first let me just say that mostly this is great.
It's mostly great.
This was the most rewarding year of my life for sure.
Uh,
being part of the Peterson tour,
getting back into standup,
as I said,
meeting so many people,
you know,
after the,
um,
after the show is we do a meet and greet.
So Jordan doesn't meet and greet and I do a separate meet and greet and
sometimes people go to both.
And usually about 50 people or so come to my meet and greet and we get in a
small room and it's about a half hour and I get to shoot the shit and meet you
guys that people give me gifts and hugged me.
Well,
first off,
no one can ever believe on real,
cause you guys only see me on youtube,
but they want to poke me often.
Um,
but people say all these great things and it's so nice.
It's so validating.
Know that you guys are out there and it's all kinds of people from all walks of
life and all that.
Um,
and it's really fun.
And I also do those meet and greets after my standup shows and it's totally fun.
Um,
so that's all validating and great and good.
And you know,
we've built a great business here.
And,
um,
you know,
ironically the day that we found out this stupid patrion on thing was happening,
we had just flipped one of our part timers to a fulltime or,
um,
so there's a lot of good things happening.
We've got a lot of plans for next year.
There's going to be a lot more travel.
I think we're gonna do more shows on the road,
whole bunch of stuff.
I would say the cost part,
well,
it's not fun reading these articles,
right?
Like,
so if Fox is like Reuben's part of the alt right and then,
and then,
uh,
you know,
20 blue check,
3000 follower,
a verified Twitter,
people tweet it out.
It's like,
it's not fun seeing that,
but it's like,
you guys are desperate and kinetic are saying.
So I don't really care about that that much anymore.
But I do think about it sometimes it's like,
you know,
I get recognized places and I could be at a restaurant where someone has read
one of those articles about me and they could be looking at me like Reuben's you
see that guy over there?
Like he's a white supremacist or some just completely bananas,
something like,
so that part's not fun.
Um,
and I think there's probably been costs.
There's probably been some business or professional costs,
but I'm very happy with what I'm doing.
I think we're building something so cool.
And even for the patrion part of this,
that is now a problem,
um,
we'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
Like you didn't beat me yet.
You know,
I've taken big risks in the past when we got on patron in the first place,
uh,
me and David and America,
we all quit.
Our jobs left our health insurance,
the whole thing to join on Patriot just to see if it would work.
And nobody really was on Patrion in the political space.
Now,
everyone's on there,
but at time it was mostly video gamers and I was like,
let's try it.
And we did try it and it worked.
And it has basically been the engine of the show for the last uh,
three years or so.
So this time around when this thing happened,
I really was like,
like there,
there was a part of me that wanted to do something crazy.
Like I still have that in me.
I'm 42,
but I guess I still got a little bit of like a crazy 21 year old in me and I was
like,
I should just cancel patrion on,
we'll figure it out,
you know,
like it's nuts,
but like I want to stand up for something and blah,
blah blah.
And then like,
you know,
then I realized I've got employees now,
I've got different businesses,
different expenses and things like that.
You just can't nobody,
and nobody in their right mind just gives up all that red.
But we will figure it out.
And as I said,
if I can migrate enough people from Patrion or we can get enough people off our
new people to donate at the site.
Again,
it's Dave rubin.com/donate I'm sorry for being at a tele evangelist here.
Um,
we'll,
we'll do it.
We'll do what?
I want to send them a message.
Um,
and I want to coordinate some of this by the way with some of the other IDW
crew.
So hang tight on some of that stuff.
Um,
is there anything you'd like to refute that has been said about you by your
critics?
Um,
refute.
I mean,
yeah.
Well I guess I'm not,
you know,
one of the things that I see from a lot of these,
uh,
whatever these critics that's even that's being giving them a nice term,
um,
was that I was funded by the Koch brothers.
I am not funded by the Koch brothers.
Uh,
what these wizards are just trying to say is that learn liberty was fun,
learn liberty that we had the partnership with,
which by the way,
every episode of every show that we ever did with them,
I said,
this episode is a part what I say in a partnership with our friends at learn
liberty.
So it wasn't something that I was hiding years ago.
I think one of the Koch brothers gave some money to learn liberty through George
Mason University through a new,
a a organization called the Institute for humane studies or something.
Anyway,
none of that even matters.
It all sorts of people.
You out there person right now you probably donate to um,
to nonprofits to right people donate to nonprofits.
Thousands and thousands of people donate to institute for humane studies and
learn.
Liberty was just one of their projects.
Um,
but anyway,
that was in like 2012 or something.
I didn't start working with them until 2016 anyways.
When people say he's funded by the Koch brothers and it's like,
oh,
I'm not funded by the Koch brothers.
Actually the person who funded our our year or sponsorship,
which I said we're not even working with them anymore.
Um,
and it was a wonderful partnership and that is no way throwing them under the
bus.
I love to everybody learn liberty.
They let us do whatever we want.
I never,
nobody ever said say this,
talk about this,
think about this,
anything like that.
They gave us great professors,
we had great shows.
We did that president's week a thing last year with them.
So it was,
it was a wonderful partnership.
I just wanted to kind of think about some other things.
As I said,
they wanted to continue it.
I was like,
let me see if I can figure out some other interesting things.
We've had a nice run with it.
MMM.
But people that you're funded by,
the Koch rise and it's like,
actually the person who funded us is an anonymous woman.
I only know it's a woman because they told me it's a woman.
So if you want to write her a handwritten note,
you could.
Right,
ma'am.
So I did write,
ma'am,
you know,
on a note to an anonymous person who happened to give the funds that funded us
anyway,
whatever.
You know what I don't need,
I don't mind critics.
If you're look,
when people say,
well Ruben,
um,
you know,
it's funny,
people will say,
ah,
Rubens too much.
Like Larry King.
Well,
I've had Larry King on here just a couple of weeks ago.
He is a friend and a mentor and the fact that he even thinks I'm halfway decent
at this is the greatest compliment ever.
So I would say the Larry,
the,
if you look at the breadth of his work,
is probably the greatest interviewer of all times.
So if your criticism is I'm too much like Larry King,
that would be like criticizing Koby Bryant and saying you're too much like
Michael Jordan.
That's pretty good.
So I don't mind criticism if you want to criticize the way I questioned somebody
or a followup that maybe I missed or some of that stuff.
It's all good.
I'm not perfect.
And you know,
I'll always get better.
I hope I always get better.
And I'll at least always try to get better.
Um,
but it's when people just like lie about what I say and selectively at eclipse
and obsess over me.
Like there's,
there's like a crew of people that are just endlessly obsessed over what I say.
And it's like,
no,
I don't even care anymore.
It's like,
what are you doing?
Like if you wake up and think to Abe Rubens,
the biggest problem in the world,
Holy Shit,
the patriarchy must not be that bad because this is the worst you got.
You got to make videos about me all day.
So Matt,
whatever.
Um,
let's see.
All right,
so one,
this is a great one.
What is the goal or where is the Rubin report headed?
I'll hold that one to the end cause that's a great question.
Um,
let's see here.
MMM.
Just check Twitter having to post and they have one tweet with 400 retweets
today.
Everything else is significantly lower engagement.
Yeah.
I assume that all of my,
I mean,
many of my tweets and at this point get into the tens of thousands of retweets
and favorites and all that.
And it's like they can't have regular people getting more engagement than them,
even though they buy all their followers and the rest of it,
a dead spin is a sports site allegedly there a sports night.
I did not know that.
Um,
let's see.
When do you think that sports and entertainment sites will finally figure out
that we don't want politics in our entertainment?
They seem to be losing market share,
but they just seem to doubling out.
Great question.
Nobody wants to watch ESPN to hear about endless politics and this is what they
keep giving us.
And I think,
uh,
Travis clay,
Travis calls it woke center and it's like,
man,
that Shit's boring.
Just endlessly talking about politics everywhere.
So we have no spaces where we can just be people who watch a game together or
just be people who play a video game together or shoot hoops together,
whatever.
It's like,
if we don't have those spaces,
we've got nothing left.
Which is ironic.
Yeah.
At a some level for where I'm at,
because I've said this before,
but in a way I'm less interested in politics specifically than I've ever been.
There's this cultural thing happening right now that's intertwined with
technology and entertainment and politics.
That's what I'm interested in politics alone about what's happening in the
Senate today or,
or Nancy Pelosi might stay on as the leader indefinitely or Trump met with.
It's like that.
That all just seems like theater to me at this point and there's just something
much more important happening and that's what I want to talk about.
But I also want to talk about the bigger ideas,
which is why I just had a rabbi,
a priest in an email,
man.
Um,
okay.
Let's see.
Um,
whew.
Oh Man.
There's a lot of good stuff here.
Uh,
will you ever invite Jack Conti back on to lie to our faces again?
Um,
you know what,
let me figure out what's going on here with the Patriots situation and maybe I
would offer him the chair to sit in again at the end of the day,
unless he truly changed,
then he lied to me.
He said this manifested observable behavior thing he said on platform.
Both of those things turned out to be a lie.
So I don't need to give him a platform again.
Um,
and I'm not thrilled with what's going on with Patriot.
As I said,
we can migrate enough people over,
we will make a move and we've got some other plans by the way,
that I just can't get into everything at the moment in front of all of you good
people.
Um,
okay.
let's see.
Do you think that the left has a difficult time articulating and defending their
views?
Many of your guests,
Peterson,
Chaperia,
Shapiro,
Brigitte Gabriel had been able to defend their views factually.
For example,
using Judeo Christian values.
I'm sincerely trying to find a opposing views,
but I have yet to see a civil interviewer bet or yet,
or uh,
sorry.
We're better yet a debate where it's explained with facts,
not feelings and uh,
defensive.
Their position.
I don't want to say it's impossible.
And by the way,
you know,
I still have,
I still have good friends and some of the IDW crew,
like the Weinstein brothers and Sam,
they,
I think they all still identify as lefty.
So I don't think it's impossible,
but those guys really are on the outs,
right?
So it's like,
you know,
I,
when I do stand up,
I usually bring one of the IDW people with me and it's a surprise.
So I've brought,
uh,
when we were in Salt Lake City,
I brought Jordan onstage,
which was awesome.
And we just joked around for an hour and the crowd was going bananas.
That,
that really was an incredible show.
If any of you are at that Salt Lake City shows amazing.
Um,
I brought Brett on.
I brought Eric on it,
Brett,
Brett and Eric together.
I brought Christina Hoff Summers on,
I brought Michael Shermer two weeks ago at the Improv in San Jose.
Um,
and look,
I think it's getting increasingly hard to find lefties.
We'll talk honestly and look,
there are,
yes,
are there some youtube,
it's funny,
this is where they'll go,
but there are five youtube or to demand to debate you all the time.
Well,
you keep talking shit about me in lying about me.
It's like I'm not going to do it.
I'm just not gonna do it.
I'm just playing a different game than then they're playing and they can play
whatever game they want.
That,
that's fine.
I know that by just talking shit about me,
you get clicks.
So all right,
enjoy your clicks.
Fine.
Um,
it's getting increasingly hard to do and the evidence for that would be,
look,
it's when I do these stand up shows,
I mean most of my audience at this point,
it's sort of like,
I think it's pretty split.
It's hard to say.
I,
you know,
it's sort of,
we've got some old school liberals in the crowd.
Let's say we've got some libertarians in the crowd.
We've got some conservatives in the credit Kasia finally there's a couple sort
of more lefties.
Um,
but that,
you know,
it's a pretty big split.
Maybe if anything it leans a little bit more libertarian or Conservative,
which would be absolutely fine with me,
by the way.
Um,
and it's like I bring on,
you know,
let's say a Brett or an Eric and they talk about how they're Brett.
Brett's a good example.
I bring on bread.
He talks about how he's always been a progressive.
He still considers himself a progressive,
all the endings and the audience loves him.
And he talks about reasons that the talks about differences of opinion and the
audience still loves him.
Try to imagine that happening at another way.
Imagine a comedian that was a big lefty,
progressive,
bringing on a speaker,
um,
who was a conservative to a lefty crowd.
How would they treat that conservative?
The reason you can't think of any evidence of that is because they would treat
them very poorly.
Um,
so look,
this was even when I was at the University of Wyoming a couple of days ago.
Um,
and,
and I did I even say this earlier,
I've been talking to the camera all day,
so I can't even remember I just said this or if I just said it's the people
before me.
People before this was,
um,
I did this great talk where I talked about the differences between liberals and
conservatives to a group of about 300 kids at University of Wyoming would be
sponsored by turning point USA and young college conservative group.
And then at the end that,
well,
first off,
I,
you know,
the kids are thrilled that I was there and great applause and everything.
But when we do the Q and a,
they specifically asked for people that disagree with me first.
I mean that there is such a richness right now happening,
especially with young conservatives and Libertarians don't dismiss it.
It's not getting picked up anywhere in the mainstream media because they don't
like that narrative.
They like only the woke narrative.
Those are the tolerance,
the tolerance people who keep telling gay people to shut the fuck up and black
people to stay in their lane.
Those are the tolerant people don't yet know.
Whoo.
Okay.
Um,
have you made plan B?
Should you find yourself off youtube?
Plenty.
Man,
it's depressing that these questions are even coming in,
but I mean,
this is the point.
This is the point of the,
of the Sargon situation.
It's like we have to figure all these things out.
Yes.
I have had a zillion meetings this week in a zillion different places.
Um,
and the meetings will continue.
We're trying to figure out all of the firewalls.
We're trying to figure out how to make sure funding doesn't get cut.
We're trying to figure out all this stuff.
I can't fully get into all of it now,
but we're trying to figure it out and I appreciate the questions.
Um,
when's your next la show?
So Jordan and I were just at the La Orpheum downtown,
which was awesome.
I brought Shapiro on as a surprise guest crowd went crazy.
He gave me a cupcake on stage cause you know,
he won't bake me a gay cake.
So he gave me a cupcake.
It was very exciting.
Um,
which then I tweeted a picture of that out and then just the usual,
the tolerant left these,
Oh look at this disgusting display.
Ruben is so prophetic for even standing there was Shapiro.
And it's like,
you know what,
I can stand there with someone I disagree with on something,
even something pretty damn fundamental and enjoy it and enjoy a moment on stage
of laughter with 3000 people that are cheering and screaming,
uh,
despite our differences.
But you guys are the tolerant ones.
Remind me again,
I just tolerant.
Um,
so my next la shows,
so we've got two things.
A,
I'm at the Irvine Improv with a particularly big IDW guests that's an orange
county on January 30th at the Irvine Improv.
You don't want to miss it.
I don't want to say who it is just yet.
Uh,
that's the Irvine Improv.
And then on I think January 9th,
I'm at the Ontario,
California Improv.
I'm pretty sure that's the date.
You can go to Dave rubin.com/events for that.
Then I've got three gigs with Peterson in,
uh,
in January.
And then we head off to,
uh,
to Australia in February.
Unfortunately,
I'm going to miss the New Zealand events.
I got,
I do a family thing in February.
That's an annual thing that I really don't want to miss.
So I'm gonna Miss New Zealand's,
which of course I would love to go to New Zealand and have some New Zealand
lamb,
a lamb.
I'm having lamb for dinner tonight.
Um,
okay.
ESPN just announced that they miscalculated about being woke sports and clay
covered.
It took ESPN about a decade to admit their mistake.
But I would still expect SJW thought to Berkeley through,
well,
I would love to know what that means.
They admitted it.
Meaning did they issue a statement saying we're not going to keep doing this.
Um,
I think they're on there.
They're crumbling no matter what.
You know,
it's like the ship has sailed.
You,
you,
if you're going to infect your company with social justice,
which is not about being social norm about um,
attaining justice,
it will,
it will cause you to have a problem and a longterm problem.
Look,
we're,
well now I have to figure out what we're doing,
but we're hiring right now.
And uh,
I tweeted out something that said,
I'm hiring something to the effect of like,
I'm hiring only on skill and expertise.
I don't care what gender you are.
I don't care what skin color you are.
I don't care what sexuality you are.
And obviously I'm,
I'm like,
you know,
playing a joke on this stupidity.
But imagine if I did care about those things.
Wouldn't that imagine.
I was looking at the resumes and I was like,
well,
that's a black lesbian.
We're going to put her,
give her more of a chance than this,
this qualified other person.
Or this is a trans whatever.
And this poor straight white guy.
Well,
sure,
he's been in the business for 20 years.
He's got incredible reviews and blah,
blah,
blah.
He shouldn't get the job.
What would that make any sense?
These are the people that are trying to institute racism into the system.
This system now basically work to do what you want.
And does that mean that there might be some HR people out there who are racist?
Yes,
there might be.
But is that the government's decision to figure out who should work where and
how we,
well,
I guess that's what a lot of people seem to want these days.
Okay.
Um,
let's see.
I don't see any other classical liberal doing what you're doing,
which is having conversation and explorative conversations with people of
different viewpoints.
You're very successful.
Is it indicative of a hunger in our society to have these discussions?
So why aren't more liberals following suit?
I asked specifically about liberals because there are many conservative voices
talking even while being centered,
you're not censored.
You know,
that's an interesting question.
Look,
yes,
there's a lot of conservative people doing something sort of similar to this I
suppose.
So you know,
Shapiro's out there with an interview show and Crowder does something and
there's,
you know,
more people on CRTV and back at the blaze and like that sort of thing.
All from sort of a right perspective.
Now maybe that's because they've all been pushed there because they don't get
any mainstream coverage where if you turn on almost every news channel,
not only CNN,
MSNBC obviously,
but you know,
you watch ABC News or NBC News or CBS News,
it's all,
so these are all lefties.
Like,
do you think any of these people vote Republican or any of these people are
conservative?
Actually,
some of them are probably secretly conservative,
but they never even admitted to their friends and they're getting their,
uh,
you know,
Karma is a bitch.
But,
um,
I think that probably has something to do with it.
Why aren't there more liberals doing it?
I don't.
Maybe it is the facts over feelings thing.
Um,
that people on the left,
maybe because they go by their heart,
perhaps more than their brain.
So you don't have to think a problem through.
You just have to feel something.
So I want to help poor people.
Let's throw money at them that,
that fuels good.
Like,
oh,
I care about poor people.
I want to give them money,
give them things.
I now I can walk away and feel good.
I don't even have to really think about it because the government really did it.
I just took,
I just took money from other people and gave it to these people.
I feel good about it.
I'm a nice person.
Look at me.
I can go to nice parties and Oh,
what did you do?
Well,
I didn't do anything but the governor,
I supported a candidate who,
uh,
raise taxes so that they could give money to poor people.
Now if you were to say to them,
well,
you know,
these programs often don't work.
You keep people in sort of indentured servitude and people don't get off
welfare,
all of these things,
they get very upset because they don't want to have to think things through
because they like their heart more than they like their brain or that where they
operate via the hardware in the brain.
I tried to do a little bit of both.
Um,
I would say I'm not that,
it's not them,
not emotional,
not that worked up or something like that.
I Dunno.
Um,
I also,
I guess it has also something to do with why I do it this way.
It's like
something happened that I didn't expect,
which was,
I was talking about the left from a leftist perspective,
from a progressive perspective and suddenly I was getting an endless amount of
hate from the left,
which I guess I could have expected.
I thought it was a little weird,
but I was like,
oh,
I'm talking about free speech.
I'm talking about some of these issues that you guys should care about,
but you hate me.
All right,
that's fine.
That wasn't necessarily that surprising was a little odd,
but not that surprising.
The thing that was surprising was that suddenly all of these evil conservatives
that the media would make you think,
or all racists and bigots and all these libertarians were maniacs and all this
other stuff,
they have only been welcoming.
I'm telling you,
I am meeting the nicest people.
I get emails from the middle of the country,
from Christian conservatives that never heard a liberal,
not talk down to them.
Um,
that,
that it's funny,
people will say,
well,
see Ruben's enabling the far right.
It's like actually I'm getting emails from people that are becoming often more
liberal from listening to these conversations.
So,
you know,
it's just a certain amount of hysteria.
It's right.
All right,
we've got four minutes to go.
Um,
let's see.
I'll do,
I'll do two more.
Um,
oh,
I'm local and I'd love to work for you info on where to submit a resume.
We have so many freaking resumes to go through.
But um,
you can send it to,
um,
I think it's jobs that Ruben,
report.com and if that doesn't work,
just go to contact@orjustgotorubenreport.com slash contact and you can submit
their,
but I think it's John Rubin,
report.com.
Um,
let's see.
Dave,
when you appear on Fox News to any of the hosts such as Tucker Carlson,
joke off camera about you having your own show on their network.
Um,
well first of all I can tell you I really like Tucker.
The two that I know the most are the two guys that I do their shows the most.
Greg Gutfeld I really know the most and he's,
he's just a,
he's just a good guy.
We've got a couple of differences that don't matter,
but I've enjoyed going out drinking with them in New York City and he's just a,
he's a nice guy and he,
and he's funny and he's a,
and he loves being like sort of ancillary part of the ITW in a way.
Cause he's mainstream.
But they did on the five the other day.
They did their people over the year and he,
he was like,
he's like Reuben Peterson,
Shapiro,
you know,
Weinstein that Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
It's like,
I don't know the other hosts have any freaking clue who we are,
but like he just is like kind of having fun with this whole thing.
So I really like Greg Tucker.
Um,
I know a little bit,
not as well as as Greg,
but I really like Tucker.
You know,
usually when I do talk her,
I think except for once or twice we've done it like I was on top of yesterday
and we do it via satellite.
So I just go to a little studio here in la.
It's like a little box.
It's like half the size of my studio and there's just a camera in front of you.
And actually what's weird,
this is just a little TV thing.
They often put the monitor so you can see yourself right beneath you,
but it's on like a two second delay.
So the first time I ever did those things,
I think it was on Hln years ago.
It's really bizarre because you're hearing someone talk to you,
but you're seeing their lips move in a different way and it'd be really hard.
So now I always have them shut the shut the video feed.
Um,
nobody's really joked to me about that.
I mean I can,
I can't tell you every little thing that's going on,
but like I'm getting all sorts of crazy offers.
That's also why the patriotic thing is weird.
It's like,
why is this happening right now?
Like,
I want to stay fan funded.
I really do.
I want to be my own boss.
I don't want to have to change anything we're doing in drastic ways,
but we got to figure out the patriotic solution.
But if enough people go to Dave Rubin,
knock on slash donate,
uh,
you know,
we'll keep,
keep on keeping on.
Okay.
There's a zillion more questions here.
We'll catalog some of these,
cause I see there's a lot of,
a lot of good stuff here and I'm sorry I couldn't get to all of it.
Um,
but the last question,
which I hit on before,
uh,
which is what is the goal or where is the Ruben report edit?
Well,
look,
we just had a great year.
As I said,
uh,
we're,
we're going to crap crash 900,000 subscribers today or tomorrow.
And that's despite the fact that tons of you come up to me in real life and keep
telling me that you keep getting unsubscribed.
Youtube says you're a bot or you're rushing troll and you don't know what you're
doing.
But,
uh,
the growth of the channel has been great.
I think the content that we're doing,
you know,
one of the things that I was afraid of during the Peterson tour was I was coming
back,
you know,
often I'd be traveling for two or three weeks.
I'd come back and we'd have to do three shows in a day and it's,
you know,
at one show I'm sharp as hell to shows and pretty damn sharp.
Third show.
I,
I'm kind of like,
it's a lot of information to take in.
And especially if I was jetlagged or something,
I was really concerned that the quality of the interviews was going to suffer.
I actually think what we've done this,
uh,
this fall starting with when Shapiro interviewed me and then the next week we,
and Peter Teal a and then we did,
you know,
we did the obviously the Peterson Shapiro thing,
um,
this interview that I just did with a rabbi Wolpe and Bishop Barron,
that'll be up the thing with the mom to Ed.
This interview that we put up this week,
by the way with Kole Valerie is just,
is just great.
Get to know this girl if you don't know her,
what a freaking,
what a wonder and a and just like a little sparkle of joy and,
and someone who knows the ideas and isn't afraid to say what she thinks.
Just just spectacular.
Um,
so I was really worried though that,
that the show was going to suffer because of the tour,
but I really don't think it did.
But my one regret,
which I mentioned in the live stream last month is that I don't do the do the
direct messages as much anymore because we just,
we don't have the time.
And also because we're stocking episodes is sometimes I taped three in a row.
The d the Dms usually are about what's going on that week.
So it's hard to tape it three weeks in advance.
But I've been trying to do a few more of these live streams.
You know,
I did one right before the election and right after the election I think I was
in UK for one of the Oslo for the other.
Um,
and we'll keep doing those things.
And I think when we get back eventually to a little more of a schedule,
we'll get back to do,
doing more of those.
I think what's going to happen in the next year is,
look,
we're going to figure out a little bit of the business stuff.
I think that these issues that we've been tracking related to free speech and
tech and the rest of it,
they're going to keep ramping up.
And who the hell knows what's coming next.
Like the Oregon thing is a major move of blind.
So I don't know what's gonna come next.
Um,
but we're going to keep building this thing and I feel great about,
I feel great about the conversations we're having.
I feel great about the people that I'm meeting.
I feel great about the business we're building.
Um,
I think it's gonna,
it's gonna go up on steroids.
We're going to continue the tour with Peterson.
I'm going to do more stand up than I did this year.
It was like I got dragged back in.
I didn't even want to do it,
but now I'm having fun with it,
so that's great.
Um,
I'm going to write my book,
um,
or continue writing my book,
I should say.
Um,
and we're just going to keep going and going and going.
And then,
uh,
I don't know when we're going to arrest,
but Emma's resting for us
right now.
So,
uh,
so that's pretty good.
And,
uh,
yeah,
and that's it.
So anyway,
this sort of a,
a bit of an odd,
uh,
live stream I suppose because there's a lot going on and all sorts of different
ways.
Um,
but as I try to always say on the,
on the Patriot and day when I talked to the small groups,
I'm,
I'm genuinely,
um,
I'm humbled and honored by your support and if you don't support financially
just sharing the videos and telling your friends about this stuff and,
you know,
people coming up to me and whole foods and the rest of it,
it's like we're doing something good.
Let's just keep doing it.
It can be exhausting at times.
I could probably use like a good night's sleep,
you know,
but like,
it's all good.
It's all good.
So,
uh,
I think you're going to really dig a Monday show with the rabbi and the Bishop.
Um,
we've got him on tweety before the year's out and I know that might,
we might be holding that one.
I'm actually not sure.
Um,
and what else?
Oh,
we're going to do a year end clip show with some of my favorite moments that'll
be up the week of Christmas.
And uh,
yeah,
some other cool stuff.
So,
uh,
enjoy the season everybody.
Happy holidays.
Hope you had a happy Hanukkah.
Hope you're gonna have a merry Christmas and Oh,
I will be in Florida.
So I do have one more.
One last Gig.
Uh,
I'll be at the turning point student action summit.
I'll be there with,
uh,
Peterson's going to be there and Kyle,
because she was going to be there and Candice and Charlie and Gutfeld is going
to be there and I think Prager and a few other people.
So if you happen to be in West Palm Beach,
I'm going to be speaking there on the 19th.
Um,
yeah.
Swing on by.
Come say hi.
See what's going on.
Um,
but I really thank you guys for your support all year.
We've got a couple more shows coming out,
so if you're not,
and uh,
all right,
I think I'm going to go have some dinner.
All right.
Thanks guys.
Yeah.